oscar isaac is in talks to take on the
role of our moon knight in disney plus
his upcoming live action series
and while i think that's a great casting
choice i'm still highly skeptical
not because of isaac i think he'd do a
good job with whatever material he's
handed if he got cast
the mcu has very rarely miscast any of
their leading roles
but more often than not the big problems
start in the writing phase
with good performances being hampered by
messy scripts
and i know how moon knight is a tricky
character to sell to a mainstream
audience
which is precisely why his books have
never been extraordinarily successful
just barely successful enough that he
keeps on coming back around every few
years to continue to be absolutely nutty
and scary much like deadpool was before
he caught the spotlight and had to be
watered down so as not to put off new
audiences
but you know what's really nutty i've
got a secret to tell you
come on don't be shy come here closer
closer this video is sponsored by raid
shadow legends
in case you haven't watched a youtube
video in the past two years raid shadow
legends is the hit dark fantasy rpg
that's available on mobile and pc if you
got one of those
lord knows i don't but it looks and
plays just as well on mobile and you can
pull it up and play anytime while you're
stuck at home all day or on your break
at work
with 500 champions to collect each with
their own special skill and a million
artifacts to find and equip
no two champions will ever be the same
giving you trillions of combinations of
teams
trillions with a t my favorite part of
the game is that you can summon
champions to help you in battle upgrade
skills and depending on the level of
upgrade it gives you uncommon common and
rare champions so
you won't have to use all your shards to
summon them and this month raids getting
their biggest update
ever the main event is already here the
doom tower it's a giant tower with 120
floors a bunch of secret challenge rooms
and 12
bad ass bosses to take on if you're up
to the challenge and to help you get
started raid is giving away a special
champion a fellow by the name of bulwark
who's awesome in clan boss and even
better for helping you take on the doom
tower bosses
if you want to get a huge head start in
raid all you have to do is hit the link
in the description
and get your free void champion an xp
booster
50 gems some energy refills and even an
ancient chart as soon as you get in game
you'll even find your extra rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
and it's that easy just click the link
in the description and i'll see you in
the game
i can't help but remember how major
aspects of that character like his
extreme memory problems
suicidal depression anti-social and
psychotic tendencies
and the fact that he kidnapped an old
lady and made her a slave for years and
locked her in a torch room and killed
anyone who tried to help her escape
all that [ __ ] was cut or simplified yeah
she's just as wise cracking roommate and
it's all fun and safe and marketable
as soon as moon knight got the green
light for a series i wanted to be
excited but instead i got nervous
i remembered what happened to deadpool
and envisioned a very lackluster show
that changes or misrepresents the
character so much that it damages him
for years to come
i know for a fact that it's going to be
watered down to fit on a disney platform
but it's just a question of how much
today i'm here to give my thoughts on
what needs to be done to stop that from
happening
and preserve what is in my opinion one
of the better characters in cape comics
let's get the basics out of the way i'll
start small and work my way up
who exactly is moon knight no he's not
just marvel's batman
that's an extreme oversimplification
that people use to sell him to other
people who don't read comics
people like batman even if they don't
read or care about comic books
so it's a safe bet that if you just
compare him to that you'll get a lot
more casual readers to like him by
default
i know why it's said and it's probably
done with good intentions but it's a
very surface level comparison
they're both rich guys with capes and
they throw sharp pointy things that look
like their costume logo
but that is about as apt as saying
sentry is marvel superman
they look similar and their costumes and
powers slash gimmicks are similar
but that's where the comparison begins
and ends at most moon knight is more
like ben
affleck batman mixed with travis bickle
he brands criminals by carving a moon
logo into their forehead so they'll be
killed in prison
which batman vs superman ripped off but
he also does things like
crash a helicopter into taskmaster to
avoid fighting him reenact the raid
single-handedly
become a hollywood movie producer tackle
his nemesis off a rooftop and cut off
his face and keep it as a trophy in a
box under his floorboards and sometimes
puts it on and wears it in the mirror
talk to voices in his head in public and
punch himself in the face
has disassociative identity disorder and
switches jobs every time he turns into
one of his altars
becomes a detective that fights
supernatural demons and ghosts
sacrifices people to a scary egyptian
deity that may or may not be possessing
his body
and sometimes haunts werewolves he's got
a lot going
on because all of this sounds weird and
out there and hard to sell
the show faces a lot of hurdles and i
worry they'll take the easiest route
possible by using
none of this which leads to our first
major point
why does it matter that they get the
show right a lot of people from the
outside looking in probably think
does it matter if the show is perfect
because the books are still there and
still great right well half right
the old books are still there but all
the future ones are now
imperiled marvel comics has proven time
and again that brand synergy is their
king and they will throw out and rebuild
everything to make it as accessible to
casual fans as possible
they want fresh new fans who like the
movies to go pick up the comic and get
the same
experience relatively that means that
any comic that differs from the movies
and tv shows suddenly gets
warped to match them a classic example
is star-lord who looked like this for
decades but then the movie comes out and
invents this redesign for him
and going forward now suddenly the
character is written completely
differently to match chris pratt and
he's got the exact same costume
there's a falcon and winter soldier
comic coming out to match the series
they started drawing punisher's face to
look like john bernthal
the defender's team lineup looked like
this and then the tv show came out and
suddenly the team roster looked like
this
iron man was a little more stoic and
serious then he's robert downey jr and
is very sarcastic and quippy and now in
the comics he's bantering as much as
spider-man
deadpool started talking more like ryan
reynolds very hit or miss on set ad-libs
or suddenly he's hanging out with
negasonic teenage warhead a character
he's never met before in pretty much any
of his comics
and now she's a sidekick for all of his
2018 run and in deadpool mercs for money
we have a whole story devoted to
explaining how her head got shaved to
look more like the actress
the only character that's relatively
immune is spider-man save for being
drawn to look more like andrew garfield
for
a little bit but that character faced
the wrath of synergy in all of his
elseworld books
like the spidey series where he's drawn
to look like tom holland
fights vulture with iron man and meets
michelle jones and ganky slash
ned or even further back that awkward
situation where he started dating gwen
stacy in the ultimate universe even
though they considered each other like
siblings and also lived in the same
house together so you know they just had
to have done it at some point when may
was out getting groceries or something
all likely because the book came out
just a few years before
you guessed it whatever happens to moon
knight in this series will undoubtedly
change the comics so if they screw it up
royally
and or do something way off base fans of
the characters suffer for it for the
foreseeable future
it's not often that these changes are
permanent but a few of them tend to
stick forever if they make an easy way
to sell the book
deadpool more or less has gone back to
normal now and stopped trying to emulate
his film counterpart
punisher's face reverted to his original
vengeful scowl
but iron man spider-man noir and the
avengers and
a pretty substantial chunk of the cosmic
half of the marvel universe
all showed no signs of going back to the
way things were
and whether that's a good or bad thing
is entirely subjective but i think it's
a cheap way to make these stories more
accessible
in my opinion the best way to get new
readers wasn't to keep rebooting the
characters into endless cycles of
repeating their old storylines because
those are now getting an expensive new
movie or to force readers to keep
picking up massive crossover events to
understand what's happening to the only
one character they actually want to read
wasn't any of that it was just to keep
telling cool original stories with the
characters you have that take them to
new places and try new things
the bigger these characters have gotten
the less they've been able to branch out
and evolve
and that sucks because moon knight's
obscurity is one of the characters
strengths
no two moon knight runs are exactly
alike and the fact that his audience is
so small and
expectations are so low means that
writers can do just about whatever they
want with him
keep in mind i'm not making this video
because i think interpreting moon knight
in a new way is inherently wrong
the books have shown us many different
sides of him but i want them to find a
way to pay homage to all of these
different runs and versions of him
instead of tossing all of that out and
just trying to start something that
resembles none of them
moon knight as a character is partly so
interesting
because he's always changing and i don't
want that to go away
i don't hate change i hate bad change
remember that video i did on lizard
syndrome and how a lot of characters are
stuck
spinning their wheels with repetitive
character arcs forever
moon knight is an exception the status
quo changes for him in
every new run from doug mench's
serialized pulp adventure story
the dark political drama of the houston
run to the mind-bending surrealist
character
study of jeff lemire's book to warren
ellis's episodic noir detective series
with sprinkles of mysticism
all moon knight runs focus on different
aspects of the character and use him in
different ways
not all of them worked for me but i
applaud them for keeping with the theme
of trying something new
all of that will change if the disney
plus show is a smash hit success
whatever the show ends up being the
character will
follow for better for worse it's what
happens to every obscure marvel
character who becomes a big deal through
a movie or series
at least in some capacity so whatever
inevitable changes they make i want them
to be for the right reasons
and not just change for the sake of
making something that will sell
it's not so much a problem that he'll
resemble the show version
but more that he'll only be like that
for a very long time
and we won't get to see any fresh new
takes on him all that variation and all
of these new directions
snuffed out they'll just take whatever
the show was regardless if it works
and make that his permanent repetitive
default state
there are a few pitfalls this show needs
to avoid to both work as a halfway
decent superhero adaptation
but also not [ __ ] destroy moon knight
for like 10 years until eventually
everyone forgets the show exists and his
books start selling like [ __ ] again and
the writers are allowed creative freedom
because they know it'll just get
cancelled after 12 issues like the good
old days
don't make the same mistakes netflix did
as much as we all loved
uh 1.56
uh the 3 12 of the netflix marvel
properties
they definitely had some issues
something to keep in mind though
is this isn't netflix they're produced
by kevin feige and not
jeff loeb given that it's kevin's gig
now there's a whole different set of
creative sensibilities
and an opportunity for a brand new
approach but some part of me believes
there's a
subtle expectation to follow along with
the example of all these previous marvel
series
since that's what we all know anytime
i've heard someone talk about moon
knight getting adapted they used to say
make it like netflix but really they
mean make it like daredevil because the
rest
of these are not nearly in daredevil's
league sure parts of them are pretty
cool and memorable but
overall they all did one thing or
another to rub me the wrong way
the immediate ones that come to mind are
filler episodes and seasons that are too
long
and trying to make the villain too human
and down to earth just to kill them off
for shock value after they don't [ __ ]
do anything all season
netflix's 13 episode format hurt just
about
every project they did for marvel every
season has at least
one episode where [ __ ] all happens and
it's
just there to fill the time gap
daredevil season one used this to its
advantage and had that be an episode to
build up its characters a little more
and show us some flashbacks to
strengthen
matt murdock and foggy nelson's
friendship which was a cornerstone of
that series
the other show is followed suit by
always having an episode where the hero
gets seriously injured and needs to rest
up for a while while a bunch of
flashbacks play
or just lounge around sad for a whole
hour cause they think the villain is one
and they don't know what to do
that's fine for one episode a season but
as these shows went on
more and more of each season was just
episodes like this
the pacing of these shows was abysmal
and they could have easily cut out about
5 hours of content from most of these
with nothing of value being lost
and speaking of that pacing problem
let's spend a ton of time developing and
humanizing a villain
and their struggles and motivations and
their goals and their trauma and then
blow their brains out
and push them out a window or kill them
with a sword because ooh
these shows are dark and edgy imagine
moon knight gets a 13 episode season
where he spends episodes five through
nine just walking around long island
out of costume and crying because
frenchie got mad at him and doesn't want
to pilot his mooncopter anymore
while several flashbacks are sprinkled
in about how bushman got his skull face
tattoo
just so he can get shot in an unrelated
drive-by in episode 11
to show how dark and gritty and serious
this show is thankfully i have high
hopes that the pacing will be a little
bit tighter knit with this show based on
what else disney plus is doing so far
the episode count for both falcon and
the winter soldier and wandavision are
both
six episodes each most likely to have
something a little more high budget and
quickly paced
so i'm optimistic that moon knight won't
drag on as much but there's a chance
they'll give him more episodes per
season because of all of these
characters he's probably the one that
costs the least in visual effects for he
doesn't have telekinesis he's not a
ghostly android or a flying man or a guy
with a robot arm who can
lift cars he's just he's just a guy in a
suit
we'll have to wait and see how long they
take to tell his first story arc
don't have spectre and all of his
villains out of costume for 7 out of 8
episodes a season
netflix marvel was so [ __ ] terrified
of being laughed at
that they went out of their way to use
costumes as little as possible to
legitimize the stories but it was
transparent and cowardly
and worse yet when they did use their
costumes it was sparingly and tied to
the character's arc or state of mind
matt murdock has to spend 13 episodes
earning his horns
while it was nice to see him keeping
them for a season he gets all depressed
and swears it off for the majority of
defenders
then when he's motivated to don the suit
again he wears it for only a handful of
that series
only to get depressed and lose it all
over again this time for good likewise
frank castle has to be nudged convinced
prodded coerced
taunted and persuaded to put on his
skull vest
just so he can do that tired old secret
agent thing where he's like
i'm putting that life behind me now now
i just want to have a beard and date
small town single moms
but they keep pulling me back in so you
can put it on for a little bit more
then lose it again this obnoxious
[ __ ] back and forth routine got old
real
fast and i'd hate to see mark spector
hanging up his costume and quitting for
good
anytime he has an argument with his
girlfriend or his goddamn spaghetti is
overcooked
or whatever other reason these baby ass
serious superheroes have
for throwing out their suit every chance
they get just have him put it on in the
first episode
and keep it it's a cool suit and it
would look
really nice on camera in the right
lighting the other netflix heroes had it
even worse with their costumes to the
point that even the tiniest breadcrumb
of an acknowledgement felt like a drop
of water to a man
dying of thirst in the desert you know
how rare it was that luke cage even wore
a yellow t-shirt
it's a [ __ ] shirt why was that so
hard
it's like the most basic and easy
costume ever and they were still afraid
to use it more than they had to
so he's always wearing a hoodie or
something else without a hint of the
color yellow on it
i i don't even want to talk about that
[ __ ] with iron fist mask
after all these hints and nods he
finally puts it on in season two to
fight crime and he had the damn thing
upside down
if moon knight follows this pattern the
best we get is him parkouring around
rooftops at night
in black jeans combat boots and a white
hoodie
is like a cute little winking nod to the
fans then he'd wear the costume in full
for one episode and then ditch it when
he sat about stubbing his toe
ah jesus my steven grant personality has
racked up a lot of income tax this year
and i don't feel like driving across
town to meet my accountant
and he's not taking remote meetings
right now
time to hang up the soup for good i quit
i can't keep doing this life marlene and
please for the love of god don't do that
tired joke that every quote unquote
serious
marvel adaptation does where the
character picks up a comic book
and then dismissively says this is
[ __ ] garbage for kids
or puts on a comic accurate costume and
then says it's ridiculous
while looking directly in the camera
every [ __ ] one does that i'm so
i hate it you actually go outside these
things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
not a million years
you gotta be kidding me
hell no this is it this is the one
tell me you're kidding superheroes wear
costumes
you look like a damn fool you know
they're all ocean right
maybe a quarter of it happened
maybe comic books would sell more if
these mainstream properties stop
wiping their ass with them to seem more
cool just a thought
but then this topic on some hope i think
that with this being more in the realm
of the mcu instead of a weird
non-canon but trying to be canon side
project bubble
there will be less shame in the costume
designs than the serious heroes on a
serious earth
the mainline mcu design philosophy
hasn't substantially let us down so far
and they've managed to give spider-man
captain america iron man and most other
characters a decent and memorable
live-action look that they keep on
the inevitable unmasking every 12
seconds for the actor to have more face
time during the emotional scenes
is virtual certainty but hopefully he'll
keep on the rest of the outfit
as an aside however don't start with the
mr night suit because it might be easier
to take seriously
this suit holds a substantial story
significance for the character
and represents his growth into a more
respectable crime fighter after being a
walking disaster for a few years
to have him start in the suit would be
like having spider-man's black
costume in the first movie or having
bruce banner immediately turn into
professor hulk with no in-between
save that for like season 3 and lastly
know what to keep and what to cut i'm
not the type of guy who thinks you
should use all comic books as your
script and storyboard and
any deviations or a bastardization
sometimes comic books suck and you
should change them
really all i care about is getting the
character's tone and the spirit of the
book right
i only get irritated when i feel like
that hasn't been captured properly
which is why all of the hyper dark
murdering batman
lighthearted deadpool conflicted
punisher and brain dead red hood to
arkham knight translations
those are the ones that bug me i'll give
a [ __ ] when you change something like
giving doc
awk a wife and his backstory or making
mysterio a scientist or aging up capped
sidekick bucky
or having deadpool's girlfriend not be a
shape-shifting mutant assassin
these are changes that make sense for
simplifying a long-running story into
something that works in a two-hour
format
or services the emotional core of the
story they want to tell
and ultimately with changes like these
the character is still preserved and
feels how they did in the books so what
do you preserve with looney mooney and
what do you simplify
well the character has a very rich and
varied history with a lot of unique
stories and interpretations to build
upon
ideally the tv moon knight would feel
like a perfect hodgepodge of all the
best parts of him from the comics
with none of the weaker aspects so what
aspects would make for building a better
moon knight
let's break it down there's a reason
people in universe call him looney
mooney the guy is
nuts and completely unpredictable he's
so
out of his mind and dangerous yet always
feels so
in control of that even when he's not
he's like a standing explosion
generally make sure he's always got some
crazy card up his sleeve
some of the best stories pay off with
him beating the villain in a super
unexpected way
that only a complete madman could come
up with taskmaster is the greatest
hand-to-hand combatant you've ever faced
then don't fight him pan to hand just
crash a helicopter into him and skip the
whole fight
you beat him in one move find yourself
in a no-win scenario hostage situation
where a gunman is about to shoot a
little girl
then threaten him so nihilistically and
scare the [ __ ] out of him until he lets
his guard down and then smash him
moon knight always has a creative
solution he doesn't get depressed and
mope around or rack his brain
trying to solve a problem in an overly
complex way he just acts on
instinct and whatever insane thing comes
to mind first is usually what works
his did is an interesting character
trait that could be used to explore
oscar isaac's range as an actor
because mark spector stephen grant and
jake lockley are all essentially
different people who share one body and
face
having him battle internally to get all
of his alters on the same page could be
a really cool recurring source of
conflict
there's a storyline where one of his
alters gets back together with his
ex-girlfriend without him knowing
then the two of them argue inside of his
mind over it jake is a tough
uncomplicated no-nonsense guy that's
charming
sociable talkative and dangerous when he
needs to be
steven is a pragmatic calm and mostly a
pacifist who lets other people do the
fighting for him
mark spector is a train wreck of a human
being who has a hard time playing well
with others
struggles with ptsd and can be his own
worst enemy but the best parts of all of
them come together to make moon knight
an unstoppable force
and even though he uses it to his
advantage his mental illness is also a
liability too
it makes him a hard man to be around or
to love his friends and loved ones
either get caught in the crossfire of
his obsessive war on crime or just find
themselves disturbed by his behavior
because he's pretty sick
a commonality with a lot of great moon
night stories is the uphill battle of
mental illness and the war within
himself
trying to accept that he's sick but also
learn to be a better person in spite of
his internal problems
and finding inner peace with his issues
let's not forget a crucial part of what
drove moon knight to become a costume
vigilante in the first place
perhaps his greatest internal struggle
his attachment to the egyptian god of
the moon
khanshu in his origin story mark spector
is a mercenary who was left to die in
egypt for standing up to his war
criminal boss
but his body was placed in front of a
statue of konchu and he was mysteriously
resurrected
now he believes kanchu guides him to
protect people on the night
and punish criminals as offerings to his
new deity
over the years he's had a very
complicated relationship with kanchu
both seeing him as a loving father
figure that puts him on the right path
and is an abusive demon that bullies him
into doing the wrong thing
it really depends on the interpretation
of that writer at the time i think the
mystical elements of moon knight work
best when you keep them ambiguous
many writers over the years have chosen
to have konshu be sort of a mystery
is it flat out real magic is it an
alternate personality that just
manifested itself to
appear as a god and force mark to do bad
things for what he believes are a good
reason is it some kind of mix where it's
an alternate personality that was given
magic power over him and became
real it's a little of all of these and
none of these
that's what's interesting about it keep
it vague and let us speculate
have some evidence that it's real magic
have some evidence that it's all on his
head
and of course use this angle to create
some really trippy
surreal sequences where the visuals can
go all out
whether he's in a dr strange-like magic
portal to another dimension
or just imagining one in his twisted
mindscape you can create some really
special visuals for this show
and lastly don't be ashamed of his
villains they're all even more obscure
than he
is and they tend to have a problem with
longevity because he kills them so
quickly sometimes
but you can develop them to be pretty
scary and interesting
just make them more dangerous and
cunning so they survive his wrath a
little longer
black spectre midnight bushman who
definitely needs a scarier name to match
the character cause god damn
sun king the secret empire midnight man
are just a few that i can name that are
pretty cool buschmann is a mercenary
warlord who destroys african communities
looking for treasure
midnight man is a clever art thief
midnight is
that guy's son who becomes moon knight's
sidekick only to be turned into a
murderous cyborg after being killed by
the secret empire
moon knight did the red hood winter
soldier thing before anyone else
embrace some of the wilder aspects of
these characters instead of making them
normal people who just share the name
and then get killed off unceremoniously
there's anything i think can hit the
cutting room floor it's all the werewolf
connections or the time he got moon
based super powers
or the stories where his villains are
magically revived from the dead when he
gutted them years before
i'd also recommend doing some better
character building for marlene because
she can be pretty flat as a love
interest
and mark's best friend jean paul feels
awkwardly utilized as the years go on
where they can't decide what to do with
him being gay and whether or not he
hates mark
come up with something new for those
guys and make them work because all the
basics are there
i'd also like to touch on the fact that
yes this character
might fit better in an r-rated setting
but it's a disney show so we're not
getting that the best we'll get is about
the level of violence in the mandalorian
where the goriest stuff is implied
off-screen like that guy who got cut in
half by the door
which i'm fine with oh [ __ ] wait moon
knight's best friend is gay
sorry jean-paul disney won't allow that
on to hulu you go
as much as i bring it up because i find
it fascinatingly demented
the face stealing psycho [ __ ] isn't
crucial to the character and was a bit
ghoulish
i just think it's important to remember
that moon knight is a character that is
frighteningly unhinged and
can go to some extremes if left
unchecked you know how the media says
spider-man is a dangerous menace to
society
well moon knight is actually a dangerous
menace to society on his worst day
but a guy who can do a lot of good on
his best day he goes to some very
strange and indescribable places both
externally and internally in his quest
to do the right thing
whether that be for an abusive deity
that may or may not exist
or just to help himself learn to be a
better guy in spite of his mental
illness
they can capture that character right
then i think moon knight's comics still
have a shot at being
pretty damn good going forward i'd
certainly be pleasantly surprised
translating something weird and niche
into something mainstream is
never an easy process and we've
certainly seen plenty of examples of how
not to do it just look at most video
game movies
but in the realm of comics to movies the
mcu has had a very mixed record
on one end of the spectrum a complete
nobody team like the guardians of the
galaxy was given a fresh new attitude
and tone that made them lovable and
memorable
well on the other end a character like
iron fist had most of his mysticism and
fantasy elements stripped away
to function as a down-to-earth crime
drama about corporate politics with
occasional ninjas
one captures the spirit of a team of
misfits in space becoming a family and
fighting evil
while the other fails to represent its
hero's world and powers in a satisfying
way
to work on a tv budget sometimes a
change may work to save money or keep
the story from seeming too weird
but that change doesn't always work for
making the story more interesting
you don't need to create a shot-for-shot
remake of the comics to adapt them
properly you just need to know what the
story and characters are all about on a
thematic and emotional level
and what they mean to people as long as
that's the same all these minute details
don't really matter
and in the end as crazy as all this
sounds i think if you do it just right
a big audience would come to enjoy what
this character has to offer
because moon knight isn't quite like
anyone he's one of a kind
and i hope he stays that way
do
you